this is a production of Cornell
University
ok so the title is I guess already
confusing learning circles and I were
clad a ride so I'm an engineer so it
would be very easy to put me in a box
with nice square sides you know the made
up of lines and it's also very tempting
to think of our education as linear as a
line you know you start out as a
freshman you take some courses and you
build and eventually you graduate as a
senior and it's linear and so I I
through the word circles up here to get
you thinking about how maybe it's more
complicated than that and then the
artwork ladder ride I should define the
abbreviation ride is research invent
design and power I student give me this
at graduation last year and it's one of
my favorite sayings has been that it's a
short walk to the edge of knowledge she
turned it around and I'm wondering how
many of you noticed that there's an
interesting word inside the word
knowledge and what you see yeah so
what's funny is I so you're a lot
smarter than me I I had been talking
about this phrase for four years and had
never made that connection and then when
she created this little graphic and gave
it to me it's clear that those shoes are
about to walk off the edge and there it
is so anyway it's a short walk to the
edge of knowledge and that's part of my
philosophy and if or something that I
believe dearly and my sense is if if you
think it's not a short walk to the edge
or if you haven't gotten to the edge
you've not walked very far I think in
any discipline you don't have to go very
far before you get to the edge where
there are things that you don't know and
I think letting our students know that
is really important you know it's it's
very tempting to let our undergraduates
think that we know everything and it's
more fun to let them know that we don't
know everything
I've been doing i work alot 'since
2004-2005 and so trying to figure out
how to talk about it is one of the
challenges because it's it's like
everything I do so I'm going to give you
three slices a perspective from Honduras
a global perspective and then a Cornell
perspective so in Honduras the problem
that we're working on is there are there
are water supplies where Honduras is
mountains okay everywhere mountains
everywhere and so almost anywhere where
there's a human settlement there's a
mountain that's higher and our streams
up there and the rainfall in Honduras
many places is half decent and so
there's often streams that are running
year-round or springs and so what they
do is they go up in the mountains they
find a spring or a little mountain
stream or maybe even a river depending
on where their apps and they take a pipe
down to a distribution tank and then on
to the town and so you get water out of
your tap in your household and do you
know about Millennium Development Goals
yeah okay so Millennium Development
Goals one of them says that we should
reduce by half the fraction of people
that don't have access to improved
drinking water and we just met that goal
okay that's really cool except that the
word was improved and this is improved
because it comes out of the tap in your
house even though even if it's river
water okay and our Clara is working on
solving that problem of having dirty
river water coming out of your tap we
think that's actually not safe we know
that's not safe and even though I
understand why it is considered improved
it's not the end goal so what we've done
is we've developed technology that would
treat that water and since 2005 our
partner in Honduras and has built these
plants ate plants in seven locations you
think I can't count it's okay there's
seven pictures up there here's what a
plant looks like in a CAD drawing and my
little bragging here is this is the
result of I don't know 10,000 hours of
of Cornell undergraduate and a few
master of engineering students writing
code so that you can go on to our
website and request the design for a
plant you give it to flow rate that you
want to be able to treat and you get
this CAD drawing and it's generated
automatically so technology that I don't
know of other places where they're doing
that kind of automated parametric design
where everything's think everything
scales and way it needs to scale to
handle the flow rate this is now the
real thing looking inside one of our
plants at 12 litre per second plant
serving four villages for poor rural
villages in southern Honduras here's
another picture of plants what we do is
we take very dirty surface water and we
turn it into clean water and we do it
all without electricity and it seems
amazingly simple and in a sense it is
very simple and as part of doing this
we've done an awful lot of research in
our labs to get a better understanding
at a very fundamental level of what are
these processes what controls how well
they work and how do you make them
faster and more cost-effective and
easier to use from the operators
perspective ok that was the slice of
what's happening in Honduras and then
let's go to the global perspective so
here we are at Cornell here we do
investigation innovation education and
design all of those things so our Clara
RND here at Cornell we are in a process
of forming a Gore claddagh LLC that is a
business that will provide the educate
our teeth at will provide the
engineering services for the partners
who end up building these facilities in
countries so our claddagh LLC will work
globally and provide services to
partners who work at it in a country or
maybe even in a region in a country at
building these facilities and then go
down one step further there are the
organizations that actually operate the
facilities so it might be a community
elected water board that runs the water
treatment plant collects a tariff and
make sure that hires the operator and
then there's people at the bottom people
that drink the water
this makes it look like this is all a
hierarchy and I'm a little bit troubled
by that so let's mix it up so here we go
so it's really like this there we're all
there we're all interconnected and we
all talk to each other and there's
sharing of knowledge and I I get really
excited about feedback feedback is how
you learn we were talking about are your
kids in experiment right as researchers
when you have children are they an
experiment and and and either you
acknowledge that they are or you pretend
that they're not because of course
they're an experiment right if you're a
child do you want to be experimented on
by your parents what's your answer no or
maybe yes and here's a pitch for yes
because if your parents don't admit that
they're experimenting on you it means
that they won't learn when they screw up
right that's what feedback does you
learn based on your mistakes and so as
you know when I teach I I often admit to
my students that their guinea pigs in
this situation right now I'm
experimenting on them I'm trying out
educational techniques on them and I'm
intending to learn from that to make
sure that I can do it better the next
time so maybe being experimented on
isn't such a bad idea I within reason
okay okay feedback so I get really
excited about feedback feedback is one
of the reasons that I work lot of plants
in the real world to produce clean
drinking water and why many of the other
technologies that have been put forth
have not worked nearly as well and it's
because we use feedback we learn from
our mistakes and we make them better
every time and we'd look at what causes
systems to fail and hence how do you
eliminate those failure modes the next
time around and never know this arrow
could go in either direction there's
communication that's happening
is it connecting like it means that if a
plant operator in Honduras has
difficulty running a plant there are
mechanisms by which i will hear about
that and that could turn into a research
project for my students to figure out
how to fix that problem so that it's
easier to operate or up on another story
we were designing a new layout for our
Watership implants and we send a cad
drawing of this new layout to honduras
to our implementation partner and the
technician at that organization not the
engineer but the technician looks at
that drawing and says ah but that's not
going to work because and he gave me
some reasons and he was absolutely right
it would have worked but it would have
been unfortunate for the operator so I
got feedback and so we never ended up
making that mistake we never ended up
building that design because before it
was built we had feedback ok so that was
two slices that was that was what do we
do first we did Honduras okay and then
we did like the big picture oh we didn't
do this part so all these guys so
there's one of these there's one of
these well okay there's a couple of
these right cornell's around the world
but really there's there's one in Attica
I'm sorry Geneva right okay and then
their implementation partners so there's
one partner in Honduras now and we're
spinning up another partner in India and
there's it will eventually happen in
other countries as well so there will
altima tlie be many implementation
partners around the planet that are
building our cloud of plants and then
each of them will be working with
multiple water boards and each of them
will be working with many customers okay
so it just I guess it's a big pyramid
scheme but hopefully in a benevolent
sense okay so now at Cornell so this is
now getting closer to the nitty-gritty
of the program and this is where you can
start thinking about how might you
generalize this oh my goodness ok so
there's research invent design and power
how do I want to talk about this oh my
goodness ok so a freshman coming in can
take my introductory course it's an
intro to engineering course and right
off we mix things up because in that
class I call it a design class a
freshman design class does that make any
sense how can they design when their
freshman right like our pedagogy says
you have to wait until your seniors to
do design work at least an engineering
that's why we think of it so anyway I
call it design and they actually design
and build a lab scale water treatment
plant that is computer controlled and
that produces clean water and they have
sensors to verify that it meets us
drinking water standards when it's done
they do that in small teams and and I
know that they don't understand
everything that is all the theory behind
it but I give them a taste of that of
the different theories so they have a
little bit of a sense of what's going on
enough that it makes sense to them by
the time it's done so this is doing
things completely out of order and I
think it's really important because then
later on when they take a theory class
they've already seen it and they know
I'm not pulling their leg about how
things work because they've seen how
this worked and they know what was
important in making this system work and
then the theory makes more sense I'm
this is the circles okay fluid mechanics
is one second film is in fluid mechanics
is one of the hard courses in in
engineering curriculum and I've always
said you should really take the course
twice because the second time around
they're things that are taught at the
beginning of the course which will now
make sense to you that didn't make sense
because you went down a line and the
stuff in the beginning you just can't
figure out how to wrap your head around
it but if you learned the stuff at the
end you come back and it makes sense and
I think all of us who have gone through
multiple levels of courses there we've
experienced that were things that didn't
make sense now begin to make sense yes
this is a three credit course this is a
three credit actually everything's three
credit okay so freshman do this juniors
or seniors can do this I actually had a
sophomore do this once as you did great
all out of sequence okay then over here
is the project so this is where students
are working on the project they're doing
research or design work doing research
in the lab and there are graduate
students there are project courses that
are four freshmen and sophomores who
have not yet taken or juniors who have
not yet taken this course and then
there's a senior level course that is
for people who've already taken this
theory class they're in the same project
but now they can get design credit for
working in the project whereas these
folks even actually get any credit
that's worth anything sorry they know
that and then there are a master of
engineering students who are taking the
course or the project for their design
project but what I do is I I wrap a
circle around that whole thing and
students from those three entry ways
into that course all come to the same
room we all meet together and then we
split them up into teams and we split
them up into teams very carefully
actually and I don't do this i delegate
this to my team leaders they figure this
out they split them up into teams and
there are mixes of student abilities
mixes of Ages of students or location in
their degree program all mixed together
to create these small teams okay there's
also a summer internship at Cornell we
have this great program it's no money no
credit come work for us and what's
amazing is is that students do this we
have like 20 students come and work
every summer as part of this so it's
amazing what you can make Cornell
students do
sorry but I know that happy you are
Cornell students oh okay and then
there's an engineering and contacts
course where I take about 20 students to
Honduras for two weeks during the
January intercession this currently
there's no credit for this and it's not
officially connected with any courses
it's just something cool to do and I see
it as an integral part of the program I
have on here I pointed to this time in
Honduras as learning and I've pointed to
this stuff as service just to reverse
things for you because in the service
learning model you tend to think of what
you do on campus as the learning time
and what you do at the project site as
as service and I actually think in this
case it's more reversed they're doing
the useful things that will help our
folks our partners they're doing the
useful things here at Cornell and then
when they're in Honduras they're mostly
learning okay anybody want to ask a
question about this oh one more thing
don't tell my director what can I trust
this many people but I I give two
lectures per semester in this course
that's not per week that's two per
semester and it's it's team time it's
time to work in projects I think it's
time for some pictures no it's time to
go alt-tab will this work yes okay so
this is a the wiki for that project
course and we divide up into teams so I
didn't want to make another PowerPoint
slide so I was lazy so here's all these
topics that are currently being
researched and each of those would link
to another wiki page where there I'll
describe what they're doing and i'll be
posting their their reports as a as they
work during this semester and there's a
little blurb about each of them which
you could read on forever so the point
is that's what's happening in that
course students have a design challenge
or a challenge if they're working on a
research challenge or a design challenge
and they're working on that for the
duration of the semester and they're
they're writing reports every couple
weeks and we're evaluating them and who
evaluates them okay so here's it teams
of three to five I said some of this
before range front developing new
theories optimizing performance
developing new fabrication methods
creating design algorithms all those
things are happening all under this
overarching create safe drinking water
the leadership structure ok so I'm
director of the program and I describe
this as servant leadership so my job is
to provide the resources so that the
team members can be successful so that's
there there are undergraduates graduates
and faculty who work together to provide
feedback to individual teams I have
undergraduates who actually read some of
the reports and evaluate them and give
them back i have a graduate student
who's doing some of that and i'm doing
some of that we share the load between
us i have student leaders who organized
the training sessions for the tools that
are used there are there are research
tools that we've created over the years
that make it possible to automate the
operation of experiments and it's one of
the ways that make it pop makes it
possible for students who can't spend 40
hours a week in the lab to actually do
meaningful research they can automate
their experiments and so they have to
learn how to use that automation system
and so my students create the tutorials
to train the new students coming in how
to use that system and I don't do any of
this my students do this might I have a
student leader she creates a syllabus
and says what's happening on each day
during the semester and she tells me
what to do she says you're giving your
tip your talk on this day and that's an
undergraduate by the way and she's been
teaching great she's going for the last
two years and then the graduate students
have a completely different experience
to I tend to have about to graduate
students only two for this program and
they end up having this experience of
basically being managing a program so
they get to do what faculty normally do
normally faculty run a research program
might graduate
effectively run a research program where
they have multiple students working
under them under them in the servant
leadership kind of way working on
different research projects symposium so
in the middle of the semester we have
this symposium system where we used to
do PowerPoint presentations and we all
sit there and watch them and we realized
after a while that that wasn't the most
effective way to learn about what each
of the teams was doing so the point of
this symposium is it you want an
opportunity for all of the teams to
figure out what all the other teams are
doing so there's sharing of knowledge
between teams because they're doing very
different kinds of things each team is a
very different kind of research so they
give short presentations right next to
their experimental apparatus so they can
actually point to it and explain how it
works demonstrate it and they do it in
in relatively small groups and we end up
spending for class periods for 75 minute
class periods to rotate all the teams
through all the stations so that
everybody gets to tell everyone else
what's going on and also gets to see all
the other teams that are doing their
thing so that's another example of pure
based learning this is now going to
Honduras so some pictures from Honduras
students getting to see the avocado
plants getting getting the talk
interview that the operator find out
what works what doesn't work what kind
of problems intended to have and just
fully engage and another thing that we
do so this is where the learning and
service are really closely tied together
so this is a filtration system that
students have developed over the
previous semester and now they're
attempting to deploy it in Honduras and
the goal of this is it's not going to be
used yet it's in the it's oh no and it's
going to be it's like a this is like a
first deployment let's try it and see
what happens and why do we do it it's so
our partner in Honduras can see what
technologies are that we're working on
and it'll get their ideas spinning about
well where might this kind of technology
actually makes sense
in their context and they'll give
feedback to us and and given that this
was the first time we deployed this
filter it also had problems and so we
get feedback about what failed and that
goes back to our lab to fix the next
semester so that was one example we also
get to look at our plants and we have to
see how they how they work so this is
looking at a sedimentation tank and
they're taking it apart and our students
are getting to see how this really looks
they had opportunities to see pictures
and to see AutoCAD drawings you know in
previous semesters but they all comment
that there's nothing like actually
seeing the real thing and seeing how it
all fits together okay this is now the
world that many of us live in where
there's there are these three spheres
there's research there's teaching and
their service and Marsha made it clear
that apparently I'm doing something that
is a little bit uncommon it I hadn't
fully realized this but this is what I
did I took them and I select them all
together and and I think i confuse my
director sometimes because he's like is
that research or is that teaching and
I'm like yes actually it's a it's a real
like there's accounting issues I don't
know there are accounting issues that
drive them crazy because like well what
does that research or teaching like wow
would I know I mean it was research
that's part of a course so what's that
okay so there it is community scale
drinking water is is what I'm working on
and what has been my focus for the last
eight years and all of it fits
underneath that so a few reflections
it's hands-on learning it's mixing up
application in theory so many of our
students are incredibly highly motivated
to do something to make the world a
better place and if you can tie tap into
that you've got a really powerful
connection you can you can make them
work hard not make them you can invite
them to work hard and they will deliver
they provide an amazing volunteer
workforce
yeah so does it work so for papers per
year published in decent journals over
the last two years that our research
results coming out of this lots of
students engaged in the 20 students in
the summer 35 students in the fall this
is in the in the project courses and 55
students in the spring many inventions
we're open source which makes it open
source is so efficient because when you
invent something you just throw it on
the web and you're done you don't have
to do anything you don't talk to the
seatac you just throw it on the web and
nobody else can Pandit and anybody can
use it and you're done I I think that
labs that are so tied into making sure
that nobody else can use it they end up
wasting a lot of time making sure that
happens this is simple our students
write their reports and it when they
write their reports every two weeks
those are immediately posted on the web
so stuff that they're developing during
the semester is protected from somebody
trying to patent it right away so okay
we have many inventions we have a new
theory for flocculation you don't want
to know about flocculation but anyway we
have a new theory for that that's that
will eventually hit the press it's going
to take a little work to debunk old
theories there's 30,000 people with safe
drinking water in Honduras there's an
hour claddagh LLC spin-off and I think
we have an incredibly cost-effective
research model in that we can generate
lots of results with a few graduate
students and on a tight budget
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu